foreign
[Music]
Twas the Night Before Christmas perfect
time for a story I think in the near
future it's illegal to take drugs or
drink except for one night the binge as
it's known where it's perfectly legal to
get drunk higher stoned
hey child
why did they have to put the bins on
Christmas The Avengers are coming man
we're taking over
this party's dead Grandma you have a
heart condition
I'm Darby Harper are you sitting down
for this
I see dead people I help them pass on to
the next mom yesterday students
witnessed the shocking death of head
cheerleader Catherine Donahue
wake up [ __ ] oh God damn it you can't
see me what are you doing here my sweet
17 is coming up in a month all I want is
this party help me then I'll move on you
look like you've just seen a ghost
I think it's criminally good haunting
ladies are you ready to get back in the
groove we got just the thing for you
there are 24 hot young men all of them
are excited today older women age is
just a number
if they're not helping you find your
groove you might as well send them
packing
it's important to try all the flavors
I was here and then suddenly I wasn't
here the devil is going on here
we just heard a lot of screaming is
everything okay in there
I don't understand what's happening to
me
you're not crazy
whatever this is
it's real
what's going on
do you really think you could get away
with it
oh God if you get off that Terror
technique
he knows what's going on
sometimes
you'd have to burn it all the way down
ripping everything out
it's strange and confusing time right
now
since the U.S left they can see the
sense of Abandonment within the Afghan
forces I want to live long enough to see
peace in our country
our country
is everything we have
this is wherein men have lived and died
and died we meet them at the doorway
to palpable Impressions on the air that
sense of somebody moving
[Applause]
I took some steps in setting healthy
boundaries and blocked my dad online my
ex blocked me one time and I just
started a different page under a
different name I'll check out all the
time she never even knew
I met someone online and you've like
talk to her on the phone and stuff
obviously so how's it going good I'm
doing this to help him think he's in a
relationship okay I pretend to kiss you
kiss your son that's gross
are you from here I've never seen you
before so many questions I'll stop he
wants me to go to a college hockey game
he likes you he's taking initiative I
have work right I have a show coming up
[Music]
two local fans are being touted as
glucky lips fans are calling for their
presence at every game I do not
represent artists who don't take
opportunities seriously Danny I'm sorry
but I can't risk my career I'm sorry I I
get that
I think there's somebody out there for
you if you open yourself up to the
possibility
let's go over the basics one more time
my family runs a bakery bigger bread a
pillar of the community for three
generations
[Music]
cared to make it more interesting
[Music]
well we ran some tests and his blood
pressure it's a bit High I wish your
father was still with us he's not dead
ambulance right got more than our entire
honeymoon how are we gonna pay for this
I'm going to make sure that Becker
family breads has its first 40 thousand
dollar week
[Music]
Do You Hear What I Hear it's country
music's most magical night of the year
CMA Country Christmas with performances
by Dan and Shay Scotty McCreery the war
and treaty Molly Tuttle Old Dominion
Stephen Curtis Chapman and Marin Morris
[Applause]
but the highlight of the season begin
Let It Snow The Great Christmas Light
Fight returns I think the neighbors will
see it for its sweetest season yet it'll
Have You Begging for s'more
hell I'm stuck in this presence
[Music]
I'm gonna be the Christmas ham what oh
don't be jealous
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]